a successful Handover of two Ukrainian
children at the Qatari Embassy in Moscow
with Qatar using its International
leverage to help Ukrainian parents be
reunited with their missing
Offspring it's very important for us
it's all done by His Highness the Amir
of Qatar who is very interested in
reuniting families this interest is
between Russia and Qatar we thank the
Russian government we return children to
parents the war separated the family
leaving the kids with their grandparents
in the Russian controlled hon region and
their mother in Odessa on the Ukrainian
side I've been waiting for this moment
for more than a
year Russia's children's rights
commissioner Maria ala belova says that
despite the armed conflict her
department has established
Communications with the Ukrainian side
she said apart from qat the Vatican and
Pope Francis are also helping with the
reunification process but there has been
criticism on why the children were taken
in the first
place many countries are misinformed
they think there are thousands of
Children Here people in other countries
have a feeling that here we have some
kind of camps ghettos where a huge
number of children are being held that
we're keeping them in poor
conditions La belova denied Ukraine's
accusations of deportation and forced
separation of children from their
parents saying that it's impossible to
hide thousands of kids who have
thousands of parents looking for them
she added a huge effort is going into
getting them home this is the fourth
time the catar embassy in Moscow is
opening its doors to facilitate the
transfer of some Ukrainian kids to their
home country and despite the fact that
Russia has been blamed and shamed for
all the illegal deportations of the
Ukrainian children the work is being
done here and now to bring them home and
all that gives hope to those who have
been separated by the brutal conflict
ulia shavala Al jazer
Moscow make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaera